by the way your Yossi video made me
laugh so hard technically is because
it's technically food but it made me
laughing I had your back the worst part
is that I keep reading it and I still my
head automatically goes to ganache yeah
I assure you the power of you you can
change the name of a food so that's just
what we're gonna say maybe I'll just do
like a whole entire press to PE section
where I just ruin and murder the saying
of every food thing or just different
ganache recipes we're onto something
there we go we are on - welcome to the
revolve Awards is it kind of fun to come
to these things I see you here with
Dylan it's like date night out tonight
we're having so much fun tonight huh
so at first we he's been watching me do
my makeup all night so he's been such a
trooper by yourself
no I had it done really good makeup no
no not this one I'm not this good but um
he's been such a trooper tonight and
everything is he doing it no he's
collecting guys you're an Instagram
fiance is that what's happening
always how are things going for you guys
since the show ended how's the
engagement going
it's been amazing it's a great happier
Thanksgiving with our families in a few
weeks so I'm super excited
your family or your family where you
guys celebrate um so my family is coming
out and visiting his family so we're
like combining all of it
they met yet our bombs on first time
they've only met their face time and
they're like texting besties but not
through face-to-face yet it's a big deal
then is there a lot of pressure on that
they're gonna love each other yeah it's
really fun are you wedding planning
right now we're engagement party
planning
yeah we're engagement party planning and
I think we we talk about wedding stuff
but we're also like really just enjoying
the moment right now and like doing us
and chillin so and doing things like
this is so hard
yeah you guys learned about each other
over these past few months like what
makes you love each other even more
I told well one hand is the sweetest
women I've ever met in my life she like
it's just so adorable and then but two
and something I've learned that I think
it's funny is I have to tell her
whenever we actually have to leave I
give her a time thirty minutes before
and then we still are sometimes five
minutes late but it's it's fun my
favorite thing about you right now is
how giddy you get and how smiley you get
around him it is this one is this one
looking for love like you guys have
Tyler towers was crushing it right now
he's having telling him yeah I know fans
saw them kind of reunited People's
Choice Awards him and Hanna you ever see
them getting back together you're
friends with both of them would you like
to see it I think they're both wonderful
people but I think
if it's meant to be it's meant to be
it's just one of those things like you
can't force anything and you never know
they're both very busy people but
they're both great so I think it could
work but also I don't know if they're
into it so that's up to them going back
to this relationship right here but wait
what did you whisper to her would you
say she just grabbed my body did you I'm
going back to you guys I know you're not
wedding planning but when you do are
there 3 wedding must-haves that you've
at least maybe talked about in a now
truck yeah I was gonna say in and out
truck good warm weather but not too hot
because we have a little diva on our
hands when it gets hot we don't like it
to be too hot so it'll be comfortable
whether that's a nation wedding in
advance we want we want people yeah
people we want there we want it to be
easy for them to get there so definitely
probably summer local yeah timeline at
least like a 2020 wedding that you're
looking at I think the next step is just
us enjoying this figuring out you know
hopefully when we're gonna move in
together and then we'll figure that out
when are you gonna move in together
Hannah's crushing it in LA right now I'm
in San Diego and so we're trying to
balance work with also our relationship
which so far has been good like I think
we've been able to go back and forth
it's been good but amazing oh okay
I think you're asleep bad I was like oh
wait where have I been it's been amazing
we've had a really good time just like
enjoying me like being us and then going
back and forth focused on career but
then also focus
on each other and balancing all that how
do you make that work are you guys space
timing constantly are you texting
constantly we're just literally driving
or taking the train back and forth and
see each other every week every week
every week we made it like a pretty semi
solid pact where we were like we can't
we're not gonna go like over a week
without to each other it's not any way
it doesn't work yeah we went eight days
we're like yeah that's a long yeah so
we'll find a way to make a happens okay
will you be the one to move to LA I
think we're just gonna figure out what
makes the most sense for the both of us
we like the West Coast your Thanksgiving
plans Christmas plans do you know what
you're doing for that yet I'm gonna go
to Bama like right before Christmas and
then we're doing Christmas in Wisconsin
with my family too yeah you mentioned
the engagement party who from bachelor
nation is getting the invite to that our
close friends from bachelor nation Chris
Harrison real relationships with and
like some good old people that we just
are actually friends with we want it to
be like close-knit and yeah super
private yeah when will it be you know at
the end of the year I'm not planning it
we're not playing it so it's kind of a
little it's so it was dreaming it we
don't know it's like family for cousin
it's in the works we don't really know
what the details we're just kind of fun
yeah might there be a Hannah be and
Tyler see runnin at this party I have no
idea what anybody's schedule is I don't
even know when the party is so like we
have a lot of good friends so you never
know
I never know and are we gonna see you
guys at dancing on the Stars coming up
soon hopefully if we can make the
schedules work we wouldn't watch Hannah
has been crushing it the top five I know
I mean I've been able to go a few times
and I'm so proud of her all right I
can't believe she's like one of my
friends every time I watch her I'm like
yeah guys it's French so they don't let
me do anything would you guys ever do
Dancing with the Stars
definitely yeah I love to dance yeah but
we'd have to be dance partners I don't
know if it works like that
but compete against each other and make
it fun we could do that no we'll see we
we love Dancing with the Stars whether
we're watching it or dancing in it or we
also just love dancing so we like
dancing so you never know thank you guys
so much have fun tonight
[Music]